[Music]  yo it's your boy gold medal Olympic  snowboarder or st. scottsburg I've got a  spicy new opportunity that could save  you thousands of dollars 30-year  mortgage rates have shredded to their  chillest levels in 40 years that's a  dope news for homeowners that want to  refine that's like a boss I'm Christie  Paul can get you into a sage kotsenburg  totally dope hungry file open for %  that's one sick interest rates credit  you can qualify with no appraisal no  income verification and no gnarly  closing cuts you heard me  no gnarly closing but mr. Katzenberg  what about all those hidden fees no idea  Sam so take it from sage don't get  caught in your backside edge while  shredding the nar on the fresh pow-pow  hooker this dope I can fake you stoked  about spicy mortgage oli pipe dragging  double cork roast beef you mean dr.  Bertoli dope on refi today you could  save tens of thousands over the life  year loan call now boy  [Applause]